У каструлі замість їжі - вода та датчики, які аналізують нагрів.
У газовій трубі - суміш метану та водню.
Гріє чудово. Не хвилюйтеся.
Якщо ви будете використовувати в побуті метаново-водневу суміш
безпечної концентрації, то будете менше спалювати і більше отримувати тепла.
Василь Горупа з колегами працюють на газовому полігоні на Житомирщині.
Тут створена така собі міні-модель ГТС і регіональних газових комунікацій -
підземна і наземна газова мерЕжа завдовжки 400 метрів.
Науковці досліджують, в якій концентрації можна було б транспортувати
суміш водню і газу українською ГТС у Європу - так, щоб труби витримали.
Навіть більше: в експерименті на житомирському полігоні українські труби
нібито витримали і чистий водень.
Тестування показало, що можливе використання водню.
Чистим воднем ніхто не буде користуватися. Але для того,
щоб статичні характерники визначити, потрібен був експеримент -
99% водню. Експеримент показав, що текучість водню
не настільки суттєва, як ми думали.
Водень як енергоносій майбутнього вписаний у стратегію розвитку
енергетики України. Проте далі різного роду декларацій справа поки не дуже просунулася.
Тим часом саме водень міг би стати вигідною альтернативою
для української ГТС, яка в 2024 році, після припинення дії контракту
на транспортування російського газу територією України, може перетворитися на металобрухт.
Українська ГТС є дуже розгалуженою.
Вона дозволяє використовувати її в різних напрямках.
Саме це робить її дуже привабливою з точки зору балансування.
Наш оператор ГТС вивчає питання щодо пристосування нашої ГТС
для транспортування в Європу, наприклад, сумішей з воднем.
Нині водень складає 2% в енергетичному міксі ЄС.
Вони прагнуть довести його до 23% в 2050-тому.
У ЄС водень оголошено енергоносієм майбутнього.
Європейська воднЕва стратегія розроблена на 30 років і передбачає
вже в 2024 році щорічне виробництво водню до одного мільйона тон на рік.
Як розповіли DW у Державному агентстві з енергоефективності та енергозбереження,
Україну визнано пріоритетним партнером з виробництва та використання "зеленого водню".
Тобто водню, вИдобутого із звичайної води методом електролізу з використанням електроенергії
з відновлюваних джерел. Такий енергоносій не завдає шкоди довкіллю,
адже викиди СО2 зведені практично до нуля.
Україна має всі шанси для того, щоб розвивати водневу енергетику.
Якщо подивитися на нашу державну енергетичну стратегію до 2035-го року,
то там зазначено, що 25% відновлювальних джерел мають бути в енергобалансі.
І якщо використовувати ці 25% відновлюваних джерел - це 14 ГВт потужності,
то можна виробляти 5,5 млрд кубічних метрів водню на рік.
Тому завдання держави - дотримання цих планів.
І маючи ГТС, яка недовантажена, було б нерозумно не використати ці плюси
Поки що ці всі мільярди кубів водню існують лише в уяві українських енергетиків.
Адже водень в Україні ще не видобувається. Це або імпортований з Європи,
або побічний продукт, який утворюється під час виробництва на заводах.
Але такий водень не є продуктом, який можна продавати і закачувати в ГТС,
його замало і він не "зелений", адже виробляється із забрудненням довкілля.
Проте потенціал України в майбутньому як виробника "зеленого" водню
справді великий. Ця мапа відображає "воднЕву" потужність регіонів.
Чим більше зеленого кольору, тим більше тут можуть виробляти водню
за допомогою відновлювальних джерел.
Потужність сонця і вітру в нас 771 ГВт -
це в 12 разів більше, ніж усієї генерації України, вона  54,5 ГВт.
Україні стільки багато не треба. Тому ми перейшли
на отримання зеленого водню електролізом і вивчаємо…
Водню ми можемо отримати 505 млрд кубів.
Цим можна замінити все енергоспоживання - забезпечити Україну.
Південь України і Схід - ці регіони мають найбільший потенціал
щодо виробництва "зеленого" водню. А місцеві ОТГ можуть забезпечити себе
на багато років, якщо поквапляться і вже тепер почнуть шукати можливості
для встановлення вітряків, сонячних та геотермальних станцій, електолізери та джерела води.
Ми провели розрахунки, який відсоток води,
яку споживають водоканали, ми заберемо. У середньому по країні - це 10%.
Можна навіть  по-іншому. Ту воду, що викидають водоканали,
те, що споживали… Потім очищувати і давати на електролізер.
Отримувати в результаті використання водню, ми отримуємо знову чисту воду.
Ця міні-модель відтворює цей процес. Це як "вічний двигун": якщо немає потреби у водні,
його можна перетворити в чисту воду, а при потребі - знову на електроенергію.
Президент асоціації "Українська воднева рада" Олександр Рєпкін уже кілька років
не лише мріє про "водневу країну", але й лобіює ці ідеї в урядових кабінетах
та на міжнародному рівні. Він бачить добрі перспективи для "водневої" співпраці України та Німеччини,
які влітку 2020 року підписали відповідну угоду.
Утім, він різко критикує уряд України за бездіяльність.
Коли ми говоримо про стратегічне партнерство,
то мабуть треба в найменший спосіб залучати державу до цих процесів,
а лише базуватися на приватних комерційних компаніях,
які зможуть знайти шляхи, яким чином співпрацювати з німецькими компаніями, утворюючи консорціуми,
і налагодити випуск в окремих "енергетичних островах",  -
не під'єднуючись до української енергосистеми,
будувати об’єкти відновлювальної енергетики, які будуть працювати тільки на генерацію
"зеленого" водню, який далі, як товар може використовуватися для експорту.
Першим важливим кроком у цьому напрямку може стати пілотний проєкт
з водневого виробництва на металургійному заводі в Маріуполі за участі
енергетичного концерну олігарха Ріната Ахметова ДТЕК і німецького Siemens Energy.
Поки що деталі співпраці не розголошуються - проєкт перебуває
на стадії "оцінки", кажуть у преслужбі ДТЕК.
Загалом, за даними Держагентства з енергоефективності та енергозбереження,
в Україні нині реалізується близько 10 пілотних водневих проєктів.
Приміром, компанія РГК, яку пов'язують з іншим українським олігархом
Дмитром Фірташем, проводить воднЕві випробування не лише на Житомирщині,
а ще в кількох регіонах України і вже працює над тим,
як саме постачати водень побутовим споживачам.
Готуються декілька населених пунктів.
Але знову ж таки, цей експеримент можливий лише за півтора-два роки.
Ми повинні в першу чергу  напрацювати нормативну базу,
яка дасть нам можливість на законних підставах використовувати газові мережі
і безпосередньо подавати газ до споживачів. І ми маємо підготувати
технічно систему, щоб вона була безпечна для споживачів.
Налагодивши систему постачання водню для систем комунальних,
ми взагалі можемо відмовитися від централізованого опалення
як такого, яке використовує природний газ.
Говорячи про енергетику глобальну, в поєднанні з відновлювальними джерелами,
водень може замінити атомну і традиційну,вугільну.
Тож домашнє завдання для уряду України - розробити водневу стратегію,
прозоре законодавство та з'ясувати технічні та нормативні питання
щодо транспорту водню в Європу. Також Київ має подбати про те,
щоб ринок водню не опинився повністю в руках олігархів, як це сталося
з іншими секторами енергетики. За словами експертів, ЄС і зокрема Німеччина
зробили для України величезний аванс щодо перспектив водневої співпраці.
Тепер черга за Україною виконати свої домашні завдання.